if you watch the news you've probably
been hearing about alphabet economics
you say that VCW save the U shape or the
dreaded L shape this is how economists
talk about economic recoveries and it's
not just jargon these letters drive
policy decisions at Congress and the
central bank decisions that can help
determine how far we fall and how
quickly we rebound but the coronavirus
downturn is different from past
recessions in fact it's so different
that economists are having to come up
with new shapes to describe the
potential recovery when economists study
our rebound they often look back at
previous recoveries for insight here's a
look at change in the US as gross
domestic product over the past century
you can see these letters appear in
different places on the chart look at
1953 in the midst of an economic boom
the Fed raised interest rates to prevent
inflation in the economy saw sharp
contraction followed by a quick recovery
in 1954 this is the V V is preferable
what it means is that right after you
have the down term you bounce right back
in a v-shaped recovery we would get back
to the previous high of GDP and the
previous low of unemployment within a
matter of months instead of a matter of
years experts say it's possible that we
could see a v-shaped recovery from the
current recession your early signs that
we got in in May suggest that we weren't
bouncing back from a very deep hole
there's a chance people just come back
and try to get back to business some of
their income has been replaced by the
government by government paychecks and
so they could come right back but it's
not a certainty jump ahead to the early
1980s when the Fed pushed interest rates
higher to battle inflation the GDP
dipped down in 1980 spiked back up and
then plummeted even further before
recovering at the end of 1982 you can
see this formed a w-shaped recovery the
Fed was pushing up interest rates to get
inflation down but it didn't work they
had to go back at it and it wasn't
really until the end of 1982 when the
Fed was
position where it could it could cut
interest rates aggressively and get the
economy back on track again the Fed is
in a different position this time
because they've cut interest rates very
aggressively already there's no
inflation on the horizon if we see a W
this time it will likely be for
different reasons tied to the
coronavirus if the second wave comes in
and people stop going out and factories
have to shut down again and governments
start you know putting on more
restrictions that could stall the
expansion that we started to see in May
and June but there are other options to
look at 2009 at the period following the
last financial crisis the economy
declined steeply when the housing bubble
burst and took nearly two years to
recover this is known as a u-shaped
recovery what could cause the u-shape
recovery this time is you have to come
back to the coronavirus if we continue
to see high caseloads and high
hospitalization rates it might be that
people are very slow to get back to
business normally and that we just don't
climb out of this very quickly so those
are the traditional shapes of alphabet
economics but again this downturn is
different an economists are looking at
other shapes to try to describe it our
economy got hit by an outside shock the
coronavirus and we just shut it down it
was almost like a meteor hit the economy
one of these shapes is the swoosh where
the economy Falls quickly rebounds a
little but then takes months or even
years to recover fully I think what
would cause a swoosh like expansion is
that all the uncertainty that comes out
of what we just experienced the way
people think about for instance do I
want to live in a city anymore
the way a business thinks about you know
do I want to invest in an urban area or
someplace where it might be safer or not
as congregated that it takes years
potentially for people to get back into
our comfort zone where the economy is
functioning at its full capacity and it
may take even longer than that some
economists say this recovery could look
more like a reverse square root side
where it drops and then rebounds
partially before flatlining for a
prolonged period of time if you look at
the economic activity index from earlier
this year
you can kind of see it it dropped
sharply in March and rebounded partially
before appearing to start to flatten out
but it's too soon to say if it will
flatline I would say a reverse square
root sign would mean in the early stages
of the recovery a quick bounce back and
we have seen that in May and June but
then as it proceeds it flattens out so
we don't get all the way back to where
we were because businesses and
households come out of this less willing
to spend and invest because the
coronavirus doesn't go away the path of
a recovery isn't just an abstract shape
it helps policymakers determine how much
stimulus money to pump into the economy
if the Fed was confident that we were
gonna have a v-shaped recovery then they
would start raising interest rates
sooner than the otherwise would they
would stop doing their bond buying
programs sooner than the otherwise would
if they think it's gonna be a long and
slow and drawn-out recovery that holds
down inflation then they're gonna keep
interest rates really low for a longer
period of time it's fundamentally
important because if the Fed is
determined to hold down interest rates
because it thinks it's going to be a
slow recovery then that will hold down
the rate that you pay on your mortgage
that'll hold down the rate that you pay
for a car loan to protect millions of
unemployed Americans the Fed has
signaled plans to keep interest rates
close to zero through 2022 the worst
casualty economically in a recession is
the person who loses his or her job and
so this affects everyone who's out of
work and wants to get back on the
factory floor wants to get back into the
restaurant once get back in the office
Congress's decision about whether to
approve more economic relief for these
workers will depend on the shape of the
recovery and as the corona virus cases
rise across the country that shape
remains uncertain
[Music]